Her low freak bitches. So, um,
your podcast.
Yeah.
Was the big podcasts
that kind of Sunk Milo.
It's kind of a combination of Mama and
yours. And I remember it was years,
it was me watching him on your show that
led us to ask about that because I saw
him on your show and he
was like God at the time.
Cause I remember at the time he
was on our show, uh, I told Paul,
one of my cohosts like Paul,
this guy ain't no lightweight and he's
got a huge army of sycophants right now.
If you get in a debate with him,
if you lose, you're a total bitch.
If you tie, you lose. If you
win by a little, you lose.
The only way you can actually beat him
with his army of sycophants at this time
is if you just demolish him. So don't
even try. You were concerned about this,
like this is like something
you planned out in advance. No,
I mean I wasn't really,
it wasn't really a plan.
I just wanted to bring it up cause I saw
him on your show saying and I'm like,
that's very strange. I kind of knew
where he was coming from. Sure.
Cause I knew that he had had experiences,
like sexual experiences when he
was younger and he was kind of,
I think he was trying to trivialize them
and turn them into humor. Yeah. I mean,
you know, his way of dealing with
it or whatever. Um, you know,
say like I owe me and it was
mutual between me and the priest.
I was molested by a priest, but I was
into it. So it was cool. He was like,
I was the predator. Yeah. Like he
said, Deuce the priest, you know? Yeah.
It's kind of hard for me to
imagine a 13 year old boy,
no matter how flamboyantly gay
or sexually aggressive, uh,
you know, jumping the priest
bones or something, you know.
Well I think it,
it sort of gives you a better
understanding of how this guy came to be,
who he is today and why he's so relishes
this role of being the contrarian and
being this,
uh,
this sort of very difficult to pigeonhole
gay man who's very conservative but
yet believes in man. Boy Love. This is a,
if you go back and you read old articles
that he wrote for publications that he
worked for in the past,
um,
there was a lot of stuff like we're going
to take on bullying on Twitter and you
know, we need to make a safe
space for people online.
This is Milo and now, yeah,
he's like the biggest troll.
Right? Uh, I mean we talked
about Milo last time.
Uh, I was on your show and you told me
you kind of put the seed in my brain,
like [inaudible] kind, Kinda like
fake. And the more I've looked into it,
the more I have to question whether
or not that shit with the priest even
happens to begin with. Yeah.
Because I just don't, I don't know.
I don't really trust the shit that comes
out of his mouth in terms of like face
value. Right. And I think a lot of
times when Milo tries to make a point,
um, he doesn't necessarily
make it by directly saying it.
He tries to make it through uh,
like performance art.
Like when he went on Bill Maher and um,
and you know, he, he's,
he's doing this whole flamboyant gay
conservative thing because he wants the,
the Liberal Bill Maher audience to
be like boom, boom. Cause it's like,
oh look what hypocrites.
They say they accept gays,
but the second you don't tow their line,
what they obviously like is people who
told their line, not gay people. Uh,
I think that was the point he was trying
to make. I thought it was funny too,
how Bill Maher the next day after my low
scandal broke was like I took him down.
It was me. It was his hand.
Yeah. It's like I took, I took
them down. It's like, dude,
you compare it. You said he was the
next Hitchens when he was on your shit.
He really said he told him to. I said,
I took him down. No, I took him down.
He's a fool. That's such a foolish
thing to think. I don't, I,
you know what I think is what Milo does,
a lot of it is performance art. Yeah.
It's a lot of trolling and it's a lot of
very calculated stuff designed to sort
of rile people up and get people active
and get people to talk about him. I mean,
that's the reason why he does this
tour on colleges. I mean, why wilds?
Why not do it in the lion's den if
you want to get the roars? I mean,
he's doing it like where he feels
like this problem is the greatest. Oh,
he wants to stir that pot too because he
knows if he just does it and some club
downtown, there's not going to be any
protest and we're going to give a shit.
It's still protest, I'm sure, but
not like bringing it to their camp.
It won't be like what happened
at Berkeley? Yes. Yeah.
What happened at Berkeley?
It was just fucking insane.
It's really insane. Is that,
was it the mayor of San Francisco? That
was applauding the protests like, hey,
fuck face. There was $100,000 worth of
property damage. People throwing chairs.
There's Starbucks windows and light
and cop cars on fire like this.
This ain't good. There's been
articles on like the Huffington,
I almost made a video about this
article on the Huffington post actually,
that was basically like,
um,
violence is as valid or reaction to
Trump as anything. And it's like,
wow, you're literally just
advocating for violence. Uh,
and you think you're so enlightened.
Yeah. It's completely foolish. It's like,
it goes in once things
aren't going their way.
It goes against everything they've stood
before. Before. What about kindness?
What about compassion? What about treating
people with love? What about facts?
Well, that's okay. When
they're in power. Exactly.
That's okay when they're in power,
but when someone else empowered that
they don't like it all kind of goes up.
Look, kind of goes both ways though,
doesn't it? Oh yeah, definitely.
[inaudible].